each year Microsoft Research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon my name is Amy Draves I'm
here to introduce and welcome Frank
close who is joining us as part of the
Microsoft Research visiting speaker
series Frank is here today to discuss
his book the infinity puzzle quantum
field theory and the Huntford and
orderly universe forty years ago a group
of scientists made breakthroughs which
later inspired the construction of the
LHC a multibillion-dollar machine which
may be on the brink of revealing how the
universe itself came to be Frank close
is a professor of physics at the
University of Oxford and a fellow of
Exeter College Oxford author of 10 books
and over 200 publications he has
lectured on every continent except
Antarctica
please join me in welcoming him to
Microsoft well thanks very much it's a
bit of an imposing title I hadn't really
got an idea what the audience was going
to be but the subtitle really could be
this from atoms to the Large Hadron
Collider it's really this today is the
story about how two of nature's forces
were united and they were united by
something called hidden symmetry which I
shall tell you about and the boson
that's named after Higgs I think
everybody's heard about the Higgs boson
which is costing 10 billion dollars to
try and find except it's 10 billion
euros not even dollars and the euros
going down fast so it's getting cheaper
by the day but why it's named after
Higgs and what it is anyway it's an
interesting one he modestly calls it the
boson that's named after me to put
something context in it the two of the
forces that we unified that started this
whole thing off it's really about 50
years ago these people Weinberg and
glass you out at the top a photograph
taken a long time ago for those of you
who know these people and John Ward and
Salam at the bottom what is it that they
had done they had built what we now call
the electroweak theory this was a theory
that combined electromagnetic
interactions the things that you know
hold you and me together make compasses
work operate the Wi-Fi that many of you
are looking at and not looking at me now
I've right
and the weak force which is responsible
for a form of radioactivity in
particular that changes one variety of
element into another and plays a very
important role in the way the Sun works
they brought these two together in a
mathematical sense that I'm not going to
talk about for those of you who know the
words su 2 cross u 1 but it doesn't
matter the thing is that the
electromagnetic force is transmitted by
photons which are the quantum bundles of
light which have no mass at all the
analogous things that work for the weak
force are called W for weak W and Z and
they're very massive so the fact that
they are massive whereas a photon is
massless immediately spoils the idea of
symmetry that was behind it all and
that's what I'm going to talk about it
also created horrible things at the
moment you tried to calculate with this
theory it gave you infinity which is
what the book is about and I'm not going
to talk about I said if I talk for more
than 30 seconds it disappears okay right
on my screen so when did they do this
well the first person of this group was
glasha at the top right there in 1961
then down the bottom right Salaam and
war in 1964 top left Steve Weinberg in
1967 and this is where we have a problem
which is this this was clearly going to
be Nobel Prize work but Nobel Prizes can
only be given to a maximum of three and
people who work at Microsoft know that 4
is greater than 3 and the prize was
awarded to glassier sallam and Weinberg
and not Ward and it's been somewhat of a
call celebra in physics ever since as to
whether Ward was justifiably not
included or whether he was airbrushed
out of history as many people have
argued and I discussed that to some
degree in the book I'm not going to go
into details about it today but I'll wet
your appetite maybe then we come to the
other half of the story which is how
people managed to get mass into the
whole idea and bring things much nearer
to the universe as we see it and this is
associated with Peter Higgs the father
of the Higgs boson again ionically
in 1964 when he had that idea so it's
half a century ago that these ideas
first emerged and only now have we got
to the point
technologically of being able to do
experiments to really show one way or
the other whether nature does this or
whether it's just a mathematical game if
he was the end of this that would be
easy except that that same year as we
will see within the space of a couple of
months five other people also had
essentially the same idea and these six
have become known as the Gang of Six
there they are
in sort of passport photograph mode and
of course now there is an issue about if
there are Nobel prizes to be awarded if
and when the Higgs boson whatever you
like to call it is found then there is a
real problem because six is much greater
than three and there are already a lot
of discussions about how things should
be apportioned and arguments those four
against and I will air some of those so
let's just go back a little bit to set
the background for people who who know
nothing at all about this which is bound
to be several people but it's this first
of all how do we know what atoms and
their innards are made of well we look
at them you're seeing me because light
shines on me into your eyes in the
jargon there's a beam there's a target
and as a detector to go and look at the
innards of the atoms what we had about
40 years ago was a beam of electrons
which is three kilometers long a target
of hydrogen whose nuclei are protons and
a huge electronic detector to see what
happened when the electrons bounced off
and that's the sort of setup it's at
Stanford just about 900 miles south of
here the electron beam came out of that
tube it appeared out here behind the
concrete is a target of hydrogen the
electrons bounce off into that detector
and that is me and you can see it's me
because it's got hair on because that
was taken 40 years ago anyway as a
result of those experiments what they
found was that the proton is not a basic
seed of the cosmic onion there's another
layer inside made of quarks so the
discovery of the quark
layer of reality came as a result of
those experiments at Stanford about 40
years ago to make a proton you need to
up quarks and a down to make a neutron
to down to them up if you're typing the
numbers in quick you'll check that -
lots of plus two-thirds take away minus
1/3 gives you plus one which is the
charge the proton and so forth they call
up and down they don't look like that as
far as we know and those 2 seeds make
the heart of all atomic elements and
everything that we have around us here
the electron willing around on the
outside of atoms is not made of quarks
if it's made of anything deeper we don't
know what it is
it's in present understanding
independent of quarks and yet there's an
amazing conspiracy that we see all the
time the fact that as we walk down the
street breathing in and out their hair
doesn't go up and down is because we are
electrically neutral I mean ooh these
old tests you see people do it open days
you put them on a insulating plate
charge them up the hair sticks up for
those of us who still got it and the
fact that it doesn't is because we are
electrically neutral the negatively
charged electrons in all of our atoms
are precisely balanced in electric
charge by the positive charge in the
nucleus carried by the protons which
sounds no surprise until you learn that
the proton is made of two up quarks and
a down the up quark having 2/3 of an
electric charge in the down quark minus
1/3 and they combine together in threes
an amazing conspiracy that three times
exactly one-third electrical charges
counterbalances the negative charge of
an electron and yet we are understanding
the quarks and electrons know nothing
about each other clearly they do it's
just too much of a conspiracy but
precisely what that is we don't know but
I give this as an example that sometimes
very simple things like your hair stays
in place when you breathe in and out can
be pointing towards very deep profound
truths in there that I doubt we will
answer at the LHC that's a problem for
you guys to worry about a few years from
now ok so what is this brought us to
that's the heart of matter as we know it
has electrons whirling around up and
down quarks
there is also a beast called the
neutrino which is like an electron with
the charge removed and that's left-hand
column up here are these characters
however nature is not satisfied with
that for some reason and has reproduced
them twice over that the electron
negatively charged has got two more
massive counterparts identical all
respect except for their mass the muon
and the Tau the neutrino comes in three
varieties with different masses the down
quark has got two heavier analogues and
so on the up and the charm have a
heavier analog which I didn't want to
show until now it would swamp the screen
that gives you an idea of the relative
masses of these things you don't need to
know all the names the message on this
transparency is much more simple that
there is a symmetry at work an identity
between up charm and top or between down
strange and bottom and so on broken by
the mass if it wasn't for mass there
would be a beautiful similarity here but
mass has got in the way the same thing
is true for the way that the forces work
apart from gravity about which I'm
saying nothing the electromagnetic force
is transmitted by photons in
mathematically QED the quantum theory of
that is called a u1 theory the force
that grips these three quarks together
we now say is transmitted by gluons that
leave them in place and they are just
like photons no mass at all
except there's eight of them and
mathematically it's exactly the same as
QED but with an su 3 mass to it the weak
force is this thing up here and that is
exactly the same gain it's transmitted
by w's and Zed particles and
mathematically it's the same game but
with su 2 but the difference is this
that in the case of the SU 2 part of it
mass has spoiled the symmetry W and Z
are very very massive
whereas the photons and gluons have got
no mat at all so both of the particles
and for the forces we are finding a
beautiful symmetry in the underlying
mathematic
which is spoiled by mass and that is the
sort of strategy that's been trying to
be understood for our fifty years so the
two parts of the story the underlying
symmetry found by these gentlemen back
in the 60s so how was it then that that
Ward got airbrushed out of that part of
the nobel prize well he certainly got
airbrushed out in the literal sense this
photograph here of him and Selam appears
in the in Trieste which is the Institute
in the Europe that Salam founded the
brochure there looks like that and I'm
gonna thought all the pictures they
could've chosen it's rather ironic so
there's a literal airbrushing but the
question about why was he omitted well
this is really what the prize was
awarded for as far as I can deduce the
Nobel foundation keep these things under
wraps until I think about 2026
so it's certainly without any doubts of
the top left there that's a glass shower
and weinberg without any question made
contributions which were before anybody
else in the following sense
in 1961 glass shower was the first
person to recognize that you could build
this picture by using this su 2 cross u
1 game so he gets a tick for that wart
and salaam together in 1964 rediscovered
what glacier had done but three years
after somebody else is already published
bad luck in 1967 Weinberg was the first
person who also independently
rediscovered the su 2 cross u 1 model
but in addition he realized that the
trick of introducing mass by hidden
symmetry which is going to be the other
part of our story could be incorporated
to do very interesting things so he was
the first person to if you like put the
whole thing together the symmetry of the
su 2 cross u 1 and this way of hiding it
so what then does that leave
with war and salaam well Salaam in 1968
also announced how to incorporate mass
by this trick of hidden symmetry but of
course again those of us who know how to
count realize that 1968 is after 1967
though not by much but nonetheless
that's what he did and it seems to have
been his Nobel ticket and ward of course
wasn't involved in that bit and that's I
think where he got lost now the question
that then remains is was it justified to
include salon for something that
Weinberg had already done or not
interesting question and I don't have an
answer here at the moment
but that's as near as I can understand
it is why Ward got left out I don't
think that he had any real claim to be
included in this prize that far is fine
where the salam was lucky to be included
is another issue but that is the history
of that part what really brings us to
the nub of the talk what is this
business about getting mass in by hidden
symmetry because that is the controversy
if any there's going to come next
because of the fact as i said that the
people who realize that part of the
story there are six of them so what i
want to really talk about is the idea of
symmetry and how it gets broken and hope
that the symmetry my voice is right
before the end of this is begin it
disappear fast so there are two types of
asymmetry one is this one here this is
the front of Peterborough Cathedral the
town that I come from in England at
first sight you get a nice sort of
symmetry in there and then you notice
that behind the front there is a tower
on one side but not on the other and I
don't know whether you feel that there
ought to be a town on the other side
bouncy Couture not one sort of feels
that oh well you know why is there a
tower on the north side not the south
side there's no reason why there should
be at all but there's something a setec
that makes you feel there ought to be
and you sort of notice when things
aren't symmetric but that is actually a
case of where there isn't symmetry
full-stop or period the other type of
symmetry which is much more interesting
and we now realise is very far-reaching
throughout nature and in particular we
believe is the seed of all of this
business
that we're now chasing the LHC is what's
called hidden symmetry sometimes called
spontaneously broken but hidden
symmetries the way I like to think of it
we now believe it's the key to structure
for the fundamental particles and the
forces of nature and this business about
mass is the example of it so what is
hidden symmetry and why we got a picture
of galaxies up there
what galaxies are pretty that's what got
them up there but the thing is this that
the force of gravity between two massive
objects depends only upon the distance
between them as the inverse square of
the distance between them it doesn't
care what direction so the force of
gravity should act the same in all three
dimensions therefore you'd expect that
anything collapsing under gravity would
form a sphere for example like the Sun
so the fundamental three-dimensional
symmetry of the forces of gravity would
lead you to expect spheres and of course
that isn't always the case for example
in a beautiful spiral galaxy you've got
a lot of structure in a plane but
nothing out of it so if the only thing
that you knew of was a spiral galaxy you
might think that gravity acted in a
plane so this is a example of the true
symmetry which is three-dimensional
being hidden in some of the things that
end up if however you look at the
universe as a whole there's lots of
galaxies out there lots of spiral
galaxies the one at the top is one
that's faced on to us the one at the
bottom is one that's horizontal to us
and all angles between so if you look at
the hundreds and thousands and millions
of galaxies that are spiral galaxies out
there they are all entered every which
way so the three-dimensional symmetry of
gravity is present over the universe as
a whole but individual galaxies hide it
that is a sort of idea that is behind
current ideas about what's called the
multiverse the idea that there are 10 to
the 500 universes out there whatever
those words mean and that's the the
basic rules that govern them have been
broken in different ways in each one and
we
happened to be in one where the electron
just has the right mass that we can be
here having the conversation I have no
idea where that science or not I don't
want to talk anymore about it but there
are people who are crazy enough to do so
you can invite them a more serious
example though to bring this thing
closer to home is when water freezes
that if you look at the surface of a
perfectly flat glass of water you're
seeing complete rotational symmetry the
molecules could be anywhere around that
circle if you now freeze it you get a
different sort of symmetry which is that
of the snowflake and here I've got the
you cut you've got the nice six-fold
symmetry the snowflake here is with one
of the dendrites pointing up at 12
o'clock and here at one o'clock and it
could be anywhere in between so each
individual snow frei hides the
underlying fundamental rotational
symmetry if you look at a windowpane in
the middle of winter you will find these
little snow crystals or entered every
which way so the windowpane as a whole
preserves the overall symmetry but each
individual one breaks it which begins to
move towards the question you know why
does it happen and how does it happen
well sometimes symmetries have to get
broken otherwise you have problems for
example driving on the road in principle
you could choose to drive on the left or
the right there's no fundamental
symmetric reason to preserve one or the
other except that it is far more stable
if you make a decision one way or the
other and no in the UK we drive on the
logical side we to the left and it's
also true that the UK's colonies and
Japan for some reason do on the right
USA as one of our former colonies France
and revolutionary countries all drive on
the right there is a reason for this
incidentally I think if anybody knows
what it is
well I actually I asked this once in the
class of school kids and what these kids
put is hannett's you know me me me no
this is yes is it because in America the
steering wheels on the Left minima
which the answer is yes but the whole
story okay I will tell you there are
more right-handers and left-handers and
it turns out apparently that those of us
who are right-handed tend to lead their
left leg so if you go back like 400
years when people use horses you get
onto a horse and you lead with your left
leg and then you whip your right leg
over and you go off on the left-hand
side of the path and the peasants who
don't have horses have to walk on the
right in the French Revolution the
peasantry then did away with all of the
things that citta stood and decreed
they've gone on the right so my remark
about revolutionary countries is
actually not exactly a specious one you
believe that you leave anything okay but
the real question for Chinese know why
does this happen where does it happen
and how does it happen and this has
actually played people for centuries and
this is known as buridan's ass in fact
apparently goes back to Aristotle but
anyway Buridan was a philosopher that
500 years ago and he weren't about the
sort of things that philosophers worry
about namely he imagined a perfectly
symmetric donkey exactly halfway between
two identical bunches of carrots and
logically therefore implied to him that
there would be no way that this
perfectly symmetric donkey could choose
the carrots on the right as against
those on the left because that would
break an obvious symmetry therefore the
donkey would starve to death which if
you're a philosopher is hard to argue
with even though you intuitively feel
that won't be the case you know you can
say well a small puff of breeze will
cause it to go this way or that way and
the result of that will be an asymmetric
thing which will be that the donkey is
eating this bunch of carrot so there we
had a nicely fed donkey on this side and
a bunch of carrots left on the other
side but what you've done is you've
introduced something which is asymmetric
you've said oh maybe a puff of breeze
did it yet you know in your heart that
something has to happen but for a
philosopher it's an interesting question
your perfect symmetry how does it happen
well let's move it along to a next level
which is if you go to some very fancy
banquet or you go to the captain's table
on some transatlantic liner you sit down
this circular table which has been
perfectly laid where you are each
symmetrically oriented around it your
table napkins and plates and things are
all there and you now have the problem
is the table napkin on the left or the
right the one that belongs to you well
what will happen is that somebody who is
slightly more aggressive than the rest
will break the symmetry by picking up
the one on their right and you'll get a
wave of right napkin grabbing going
around the table and the meal can start
okay what then becomes interesting is if
we make this even bigger let's imagine
you've got 800 people around a table
then what can happen is that over there
you so grabbed a napkin on your left
which caused a wave of left napkin
grabbers to come down that side of the
room and that lady over there picked on
the right making the right wave come
around here and then you get something
interesting happen
you've got no napkins at all and you
have got two and this is an analogy for
what actually happens in metals that
become magnetized when you cool them
that you've got little magnetic atoms or
molecules wobbling around at high
temperature every which way you start
calling it down and not all will be
jiggling at exactly the same rate as a
distribution and - they're moving slower
than the average will sort of lock in on
each other over there making North Pole
that away causing this right napkin
grabbers analogy to make lots of north
poles down this side whereas you lot
will perhaps been linked into to over
here making them over that side so you
get domains of magnetism with a
dislocation down the middle so this is a
very well-known phenomenon in
solid-state physics and magnetism and
many other places as well but even then
you sort of feel yes but you know he's
sort of set it up in an artificial way
that's because the atoms were jiggling
around and that's what broke the
symmetry what happens if I lower the
temperature so that I go right down to
absolute zero of temperature where
they're not moving at all then what
happens then what happens is the quantum
gets you you can't both localize the
atom precisely and know what it's doing
so however you tried the
fundamental uncertainty principle of
quantum mechanics at the end of the day
forces things like this to happen so
what is the common feature that's going
on oh well shopping trolleys is another
one that we all know you know you push
as carefully as you can pushing your
shopping trolley all the one of the
airport and it gets in mind of its own
and goes every which way okay what is
happening is this in all of these
examples you have got the situation
which I've sillas traitor's I had that
burdens asset at table that hump if you
recall if you've got a ball balance at
the top of the hump it is metastable the
slightest systems will make it roll one
way or the other so it is a nicely
symmetric configuration but it's not the
most stable one coming tone you learn
something here so what you have is
you're making a choice I can have a
highly symmetric but unstable as against
an asymmetric and more stable so each of
those examples that we looked at was
giving up symmetry for stability and
it's chance that went that way or that
way so this is the background to the
idea that was going on with these
gentlemen that I told you about earlier
the attempt to build a theory linking
the electromagnetic and the weak forces
which starts off beautifully
mathematical if you pretended that not
just the photon but all of these other
beasts had got no mass at all that's the
perfect symmetric case and what you want
to end up with is the real world where
the W particles are massive so the
analog is that that is in some sense
more stable even though it's not
symmetric so you want to try to use this
idea of hiding symmetry by this sort of
game to introduce the mass so what does
this all mean in reality how do they do
it well at first sight you get the
impression that you can't do it there's
a let's just think of this really as a
ball sitting on the top of this hump and
the ball can roll down anyway
or it could roll around the bottom
anyway because it could go from the hump
on the east direction or the west
direction or the north or south or
anywhere between if it's the snowflake
that is falling it could have started
off in the 12 o'clock position or
slightly off it or anywhere between each
of those individual snowflakes is as
good as the other and all you're doing
to go from that picture to that picture
is just rotating your head a bit it's
called a global change everything in the
university rotates a bit and you appear
to gone from one to the other because
you know energy to do it and in the real
world analog of quantum field theory
going from one configuration to the next
around the bottom of that rim where
they've all that the same energy
corresponds to a wave going around there
with no energy like the napkin grabbing
and a wave with no energy corresponds to
a particle with no mass and it turns out
that this would have to be a particle
with electric charge in these models
with no mass and such things do not
exist and that in 1961 was thought to
put an end to the whole thing very nice
idea to try to use these things and
apply them in field theory but
unfortunately nature doesn't do it that
way end of story except it was then
discovered that there was a loophole and
that if in addition to the little
picture we've got here of a ball rolling
down the slope there were long-range
forces present as is the case if you've
got massless things like photons or
other particles around there was a
loophole it's become known as the Higgs
mechanism except that it isn't the Higgs
mechanism because there were several
people that knew of it before one of
them especially tragic for our story
because it involves Jerry gur Alec and
John Ward and it's this that in 1964 we
saw John Ward and Selam the top they're
building their model of the
electromagnetic and weak interactions
built around this su 2 x yuan structure
but they didn't understand math they
were just ignoring that
meanwhile in the very same institution
Imperial College in London Gerry
qur'anic who do nothing at all about su
2 cross u 1 and suchlike was interested
in how to get mass into theories and he
had solved that one one day he and JC
Ward went to lunch together now Ward was
quite a senior physicist at that time
and go around it was a young postdoc so
I imagine someone nervously tries to get
a conversation going but Ward was quite
a sort of suspicious character and
around they could hardly started
speaking before Ward said have you
published these ideas have you told
anybody about them and growling said no
no
then stop speaking immediately because
people will steal your ideas and so ger
Alex stopped there and then and didn't
dare ask Ward what Ward was doing the
result was that they left that dinner
party qur'anic being totally unaware of
su 2 plus u1 and Ward being totally
unaware of how to put mass into it if
they continued talking another 10
minutes the pair of them could have
solved the whole thing there and then
and they would probably share the nobel
prize many years ago but that is not how
it happened what we have happened is
that there are in addition to garlic
this group of six people all of whom in
the space of a few weeks came up with
the same way of getting around the what
we came to knows the Goldstone boson
problem how to give mass the things and
this is what the Gang of Six as they're
now known are and the papers in which
they publish the ideas were published
over a very few weeks and this is you
look on the top there fizz left letters
volume 12 obviously comes before volume
13 and page three to one obviously comes
poor page 585 so that is the order of
priority you would expect these people
to have if you read Stephen Weinberg's
1971 paper if however you look at
another paper a couple of years ago
every year every two years there's a big
sort of book published called the
particle data tables which has all
information about particles in it and
they have little mini reviews and when
these mini reviews was reviewing the
whole business about the Higgs boson
whatever it should be called
and they have got the references in
there let's just flip back and forward
you've seen the top two in Weinberg it's
phys Rev letters and in this review it's
physics letters in fact neither of these
is correct that is the correct one the
interesting people who like to be
sociologists or trace Darwinian
evolution you can go through the Richard
Weinberg's paper has been cited several
thousand times it's one of the most
highly cited papers in the subject and
this incorrect reference has propagated
through it shows that people reference
what other people have referenced
without actually reading it and so it
gives the impression that Higgs did it
first
whereas in fact the order of events is
that browser non-glare published first
on the 26th of June Higgs completely
independently wrote the same basic ideas
down on the 27th of July a different
journal and then qur'anic Hardiman
kibble independently although by that
stage these papers were now out there
published in October that year if that
was the whole story then you might
wonder why the Higgs boson is called off
the Higgs the answer is because I'm not
talking about the boson I'm talking
about how you give masses to particles
so what's the boson got to do with
things well the boson in Higgs have just
Joe back Higgs wrote two papers the
first one the 27th of July showed how to
give master things on the 31st of August
he wrote a further paper which included
what we now call the boson I asked brown
on glare why didn't you include any
mention of the boson and they said what
we thought it was obvious and indeed it
is of everything is obvious with
hindsight of course but to be fair to
them the examples that I gave you first
of all about hidden symmetry and
spontaneous breaking of symmetry I said
you know magnetism the magnets little
locking in that phenomenon was
well-known in condensed matter physics
which is what browse and on where
speciality was in that field the analogs
of what we call the Higgs boson were
already known and these people indeed
regarded it as obvious they didn't draw
attention to it in particle physics
Relic harder and kibble in their paper
they implicitly have it but they also
don't mention it
the only one that mentioned it was Higgs
and he agreed with breath and um glare
it is obvious but he mentioned it now
you might say at this point well big
deal
so what well there is an interesting so
what here which sure is the punchline
that we're coming to in a moment or two
so let's just try to tie up what has
happens with what I call the bosons this
picture of this whether it's the base of
a wine bottle or a Mexican hat whatever
you call it just think of it is a
realistic case of a ball sitting at the
top of some gravitational potential
which is in this highly metastable
configuration but can spontaneously
through some slight perturbation drop
somewhere or other it can drop into the
rim and the issue back in 1961 before
all this was sorted out was this problem
that the ball could be anywhere around
the rim and to rotate from one to the
next cost you know energy and that would
correspond in the field theory example
to the presence of what was known as a
Goldstone boson a massless thing which
does not exist and the problem that they
Gang of Six were all trying to solve and
did solve with how to get around the
problem how to get rid of the Goldstone
boson and they found that it was indeed
possible to do that in the presence of
massless fields like the photon giving
the mass and that was the solution of
the Gang of Six what they were focusing
on totally was what happens when the
ball rolls around the bottom of the rim
Higgs alone pointed out that there are
three dimensions here the height of it
is the potential that's making the ball
roll was the radial what does the
angular one which they were all worrying
about but there's also a radial one
where the ball can roll up and down the
base of the valley the ball rolling up
and down the base of the valley in field
theory corresponds to a massive boson
Higgs was the only one who drew
attention to that so in the sense it was
trivial but the point about it though is
it's incredibly important for testing
whether the whole idea is really
nature does it and that is what has led
to the boson that's named after me as he
calls it and the paper where he actually
really gets to it is two years later in
1966 because that is the one I think
that started off the whole of the
excitement in particle physics for the
following reason what we have had
through the talk is this whole
background the idea that the forces of
nature are described by a common
mathematical system with one feature
that mass gets in the way to spoil it we
discovered that the basic particles of
nature seemed to have a symmetry to them
except that mass spoiled it and that all
of these people found hitting it mass in
by this particular trick but only Higgs
realize there's a further implication
the presence of a massive boson and this
is the key feature it's all very well to
write down mathematics that does
beautiful things but how do we know
whether nature actually does it that way
or not you have to have an experiment to
test it and the point about this massive
boson of Higgs is this if it's the case
that the mass of the quarks and the
electron and the W and Z is due to what
I would call the mechanism the mass
mechanism
it's the decays of this highly unstable
massive boson that will test whether
that is how it works or not this boson
lives if it exists it lives for a very
brief moment and decays into things that
you can detect the relative amounts of
different varieties of quark or of
electrons and muons or WS and Z's and so
forth will test whether their mass has
really come from this mechanism or not
that is why searching for the boson is
critically important that is the only
way that we know how to test whether
this whole idea is what nature does or
merely what mathematicians have done so
that's why finding the most the boson
that's named after Higgs I think is the
key to the whole business so to end that
is what the Large Hadron Collider is
attempting to do among many other things
I just thought I'd show you quick three
cartoons the Large Hadron Collider each
of which of totally uninformative
the first one is that is an artist
impression of a tube going around under
the ground and a detected where the
beams of protons smash into each other
to create the conditions where if you're
lucky Higgs boson might appear if it
does appear you've got to be able to
identify it out of a host of other
things you have these huge detectors
this is an artist's impression of the
sort of collision that's happened at the
middle of a detector whoo detector here
I have no idea what these things are but
it looked like sort of trash bins that
have been to place down the bottom of
the thing and then the pitch you keep
seeing the media all the time which
shows the Atlas detector very impressive
if thought that's not the answers
detector at all it's completely empty
space which is now filled by the Atlas
detector but anyway that's right but
that is definitely Peter Higgs standing
in front of another detector which all
reminds me of I think was Alfred
Hitchcock who claimed that he was the
first person to get six on the screen
behind the train going into the tunnel
and that looks somewhat like there so I
think the summary of it is that how
nature builds the boson or whatever it
is and performs the magic only nature
knows I think that the fact that the
work that Weinberg Selam Rochelle and
Ward did in building this model of the
electroweak force ignoring mass when you
combine it with the mass mechanism that
these six people found gives you the
possibility to build a complete quantum
theory which is what two people who I
haven't mentioned today but I mentioned
in the book in great detail at often
Veltman managed to do they produced from
that a quantitative theory that has been
tested now to about one part in 10,000
and it works the fact that it works
using these ideas means that either
these ideas are how nature really does
it or there's a huge conspiracy going on
I don't believe in conspiracies so I
don't think that many of us have any
real doubt that this is the way that
nature has done it but the details of
how nature has done it I haven't got a
clue
whether it's just a simple single
massive boson as Higgs said 50 years ago
well if nature's done it that simply to
be very much surprising though it's
possible in that 50 years it happened
since then we've got much more insights
about phenomena and the possibility that
there's a whole family of things called
Higgs inos and everything else like that
could be the case it's possible that the
Higgs particle is not a fundamental
thing but it's itself a composite of
other things called techniquarks
or maybe something else the exciting
thing about science is I'm pretty sure
that something is going on and that we
are in the right regions to find out
what it is we're at the moment only
nature knows once we know the answer I
better that be as obvious as everything
but if it was obvious now I'll be
writing it down that's what the exciting
thing about science is so that was
really one part of the story but only
had you know the 40 minutes today I
don't have another five hours because my
voice wouldn't last more than two
minutes more so thank you for that